the Lin's it's fantastic to see you here
at MCM today now you've done so much
work Nikita so you kick ass we've seen
you in How I Met Your Mother as well the
big secret now what did you think when
you heard that that was actually gonna
get a spin-off show um I was really
excited about it
the writers Craig and Carter are pretty
brilliant in my opinion they really know
how to stretch a story out in such a
unique and comedic way for so many years
so I mean they're gonna they're going to
make many shows that are going to be
fantastic
do you think there's any chance that
we'll see you in How I Met Your dad um I
don't think so I don't think the two
worlds are colliding but that's okay now
of course you did that many years ago
didn't you filmed it how was it
obviously you kept that secret over the
years but when people kind of pressing
you in interviews about what was
happening yeah we shot that nine years
ago because David Henry who plays my
brother was growing so fast
that you know it takes place in one
story so we were like oh my god he grew
four shoe sizes and his voice dropped
what's happening so we kind of did it
all at once and yeah people ask a lot
and I don't know when you have a secret
for so many years you kind of forget it
doesn't become tempting to tell people
anymore because I mean I really just
didn't want to spoil it so and how did
you feel about the finales it was kind
of a mixed reception I guess among fans
wasn't though yeah I you know I can
understand why you know people for so
many years they hold these characters so
dear to their hearts and you know it's
in your family room with you every day
and so you get very protective of what's
going to happen so you can't please
everybody but I personally really liked
it
you